[Musique]
il éclipse a fait aujourd'hui c'est fait
dix ans que j'attends que gelée prévu
j'ai pris mes grands parents il ya cinq
ans je l'avais dit le 11 août à 11
heures je serai chez vous pour tous les
astronomes cette éclipse totale c'est le
jour de leurs voeux un moment
irremplaçable attendu désir est préparé
depuis longtemps mais aujourd'hui sur
fécamp la météo leur a provoqué des
sueurs froides
ces nuages et quelques gouttes de pluie
ont bien failli gâcher la fête
on attend une éclaircie qui aura
peut-être de la peine à revenir en
actions le ciel se dégage début du
spectacle c'est le faut les aider génial
une minute
l'art est mondiale et la chine est la
lumière mais ça c'est fabuleux
hong kong lors de la lumière
parce qu'elle ait pu céder regardez ça
ah là là là haut on l'a tous eu un
moment de bonheur un petit peu quand
tout était sombre d'inquiétude et quand
des cas lumière est revenue à un bonheur
intense c'est très extraordinaire
là il ya le croissant qu'il ne devrait
apparaître sa s'allonge sur les côtés et
on voit les petits grains de lumière
juste sur le bord de la lune et puis il
ya une lumière un peu blanche l'asse un
effet un peu électriques
c'est assez étonnant le plus émouvant je
pense aisé lorsque le l'ombre est arrivé
et la nuit noire et s'est installé
autour de nous c'était je pense pour moi
le moment le plus fort ensuite j'ai eu
la chance de regarder à travers le
télescope de voir les deux j'ai eu deux
fois dix secondes et j'ai vu les petites
flamme autour de la lune c'était les
éruptions c'était formidable
ça donne envie de voir toutes les autres
de partir très loin de vraiment un
chasseur d'éclipsés les prochains 12
mois et la prochaine éclipse totale de
soleil est prévue en 2001 au dessus du
golfe du mozambique tous à vos
télescopes
[Musique]